字幕: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Takahiro Shimpo
みなさん 美味しいご飯好きですか？
好きじゃないっていう人 います？
いたらちょっと悲しいんですけど
好きですよね？
この美味しいご飯って
材料何でできていると思われます？
種とか色々ありますけど
肥料って大事な材料です
では肥料って何からできていると
思われますか？
肥料って言っても色々ありますけど
例えばこの中の
一番主だった肥料の化学肥料の中では
一番主だったもののうち
窒素肥料というものがありますが
それはかなりの割合
天然ガスから作られています
例えば自動車
自動車がどういう風に作られているか
最初は鉄鋼石だったのが
工場で鉄の板を作って
その鉄の板を加工して自動車ができる
これを農業に置き換えてみると
畑っていう生産設備に
種とか肥料とか
そういった原材料を投入して
目的のものを栽培する
一緒なんですね 構造
だから農業者はエンジニアです
生産設備を使って材料から
目的のものを作るエンジニア
そうですよね？
みなさん 農業って
どういう風な産業だと思われますか？
これは日本国内に限った
言い方になりますけど
担い手の高齢化だとか
国際競争の激化
あとはこういう風に使われていない畑が
どんどん増えてきてしまっている
いろいろ問題が多い産業だ
そういうイメージをお持ちの方が
たくさんいらっしゃると思います
もう十年ほど前になりますが
農作物の流通の仕事に
携わったことがありまして
そこでそういった問題に
身近に接することができました
先程 農業者はエンジニア
というお話をしましたが
エンジニアだったら問題に接したときに
問題の解決は技術でしたい
エンジニアだったらそう考えるものです
今日は今までどういう風に
技術開発に向かい合ってきたのか
についてお話します
でもみなさん 農業について
あまり興味持たなくていいですよ
あの 競合が増えても嫌なんで（笑）
他の業界だったらどうなるのかな？
って考えてくださいね
さて こちらのグラフ
これが農薬と化学肥料の
ここしばらくの値段の推移なんですけど
どんどん値段が上がっています
特に肥料の値段って
すごい上がり方をしているんですね
じゃあ これを使わないで
農薬や化学肥料を使わないで
美味しい野菜が十分な量作れたら
これはどういう農業を営むか？
っていうことにあたって
すごく魅力的な選択肢になります
でもですね 野菜の無農薬栽培って
非常に難しいと言われています
まあ 品目にもよりますけど
非常に難しいと言われている
実際みなさんも 無農薬栽培の野菜って
どういうイメージですか？
絶対農薬を使わないと
絶対虫がついてしまう
無農薬で育てようと思ったら
虫を手で取らないといけないから
すごく手間がかかる
だから高く売れても割に合わない
そういう風に思われてることも
多いかと思います
その 流通の仕事をしていたときも
みなさん 無農薬栽培なんて無理だって
みなさん仰られていたんですね
ただ じゃあ 完全にゼロかというと
あ 今それで これが
日本国内での野菜の流通量 生産量の中で
無農薬栽培のものの割合が0.2％
若干古いデータなんですけども
0.2%って言われています
これは政府から認証を
受けているものだけなので
実際には認証を取らずに
やっている部分もありますし
ちょっと古いデータなので
今はもうちょっとあるかもしれないですけど
それでもごくわずかです
だから実際難しいんですね
作っている人がすごく少ないんですよ
じゃあゼロかというとゼロじゃなくて
場所は京丹後市
京都の一番北の方です
流通の時に出会った
京丹後市の青木さんという方が
無農薬・無化学肥料で
ものすごく素晴らしい野菜を
作っていらっしゃったんですね
もし この青木さんが
していらっしゃることが
誰でもどこでもできるようになったら
色んな問題の解決に
繋がるんじゃないか？
それがスタートでした
そう思って
生命科学の知識のあるメンバーを
会社に迎え入れて
２年間 青木さんに頼み込んで
「調査させてください」とお願いして
何が その畑で起きているか
調査させてもらいました
そしたら色んなことが分かったんです
場所は変えて
奈良県の桜井市
ここで丁度その調査が
２年間終了したときに
その調査にあたった
メンバーの大学院の同級生が
なぜか全く農家出身でもないし
農業の経験も
ほとんどないっていうような状態で
いきなり農業を始めたいって
言い出したんですね
これ 「セレクトファーム」っていう名前で
農場を始めたんですけども
そこと今は協力関係を築いて
一緒に研究開発を
やっているんですけれども
そちらにその２年間の調査のデータを
全て渡したんです
じゃあ 何が起きたか？
1年目からできたんですね
キャベツって数ある野菜の中でも
特に無農薬栽培が非常に難しい品目
だと言われているキャベツも含めて
初年度から無農薬で
良いものができたんですよ
これは今年の夏のバジル
これは去年の大根ですかね
今まで 過去にこのセレクトファームでは
60品目か70品目くらいの野菜を
栽培してきています
この写真は数年前の
ブロッコリなんですけど
これ今ちょうど
採れているブロッコリですね
さきほど無農薬だったら絶対虫がつく
みたいなお話をしましたけど
虫つかないんですよ
ほとんどつかないんですね
きれいに作ったら
よく虫がついている野菜の方が
美味しいみたいなお話って
あるかとおもうですけど
あれは嘘です
虫はついていない方が
絶対美味しいです（笑）
人間が美味しいと思うものと
虫が美味しいものって違うので
虫が美味しいと思うものは
大抵人間にはそんなに美味しくないです
だから 無農薬でもきれいに作ったら
美味しくてきれいなものができて
しかも虫がつかないっていうことは
虫を取るような手間も
かからないんですね
当たり前ですけど
農薬を撒く手間もかからないんですよ
農薬を撒くって重労働ですよ
薬を撒くんで
真夏でも全身レインコート
みたいなのを着込んで
重い噴霧器と農薬の入ったタンクを背負って
撒かなきゃならないんですよ
大変なんですよ
それもしなくていい
こちらのブロッコリの時なんかは
生育が早かったもんだから
雑草よりもブロッコリの方が強くて
雑草を抜く手間もほとんど
かからなかったと聞いています
これ ブロッコリなんですけど
これ キャベツ
これ今できているキャベツ
こんな風にできるんですよ
分かります？
これ あの その辺で
買ってきたんじゃないですよ
ちゃんとセレクトファームでできた
キャベツですよ（笑）
今までまだまだ これから
クリアしていかなきゃいけない問題
ってたくさんあるんですけども
でも現時点でもう ２つは大きな壁を
越えて来れたかなって
いう風に思っています
１つはそもそも無農薬・無化学肥料で
こういったものを
作ることができるということ
どこでも
もう１つは 未経験でも
正しい知識さえあれば
できるっていうこと
もちろん そこをスタートとして
経験を積むことによって
さらに上を目指すっていうことは
あると思うんですけれども
未経験でも 正しい知識さえあれば
ある程度のものは作れる
その２つのことはもう
分かったかなと思っています
でもこれ２つとも結構
常識からは外れてますよね
結構これ始めるときにもう
偉い先生とかベテランの方とかには
「そんなん無理だからやめとけ」
みたいな話って
結構あったんですけれども
もしそういった言葉を信じていたら
今はここまでさえもたどり着けて
いなかっただろうなと思います
でもまあ じゃあ その常識とかを
疑えというとなかなか
簡単なんですけど
どちらかというと
どういう風に常識を疑うか
というとことが非常に難しいなあと
感じていまして
今日は良いところばかり
お話したんですけれども
実際もちろん失敗とか
大変だったことっていうのも
たくさんあるんですね
そういったときに役に立つのはやっぱり
目の前にある現象を見たときに
それを説明できる根拠は
どういう根拠が必要なのか？
更にその根拠の裏も当たってみる
その根拠を元にしたら
例えば ここ 違う場合になったら
どういう風に状況が変わるのか？
そういう風に話自体を組み立てなおす
そういった力が非常に
大事なんだなあって感じています
だから 結構偉い先生とか
ベテランの方が
お話されていることでも
よくよく突き詰めていってみると
実は曖昧な根拠
根拠に曖昧な部分があったり
とかって結構あって
それってすごい
チャンスだと思うんですよ
そこをちゃんと本当に正しい根拠に
置き換えてやれば
新しい世界が開けるんですね
だからそういったところで
まだまだなんていうか
切り拓いていける道はたくさん
あるんじゃないかなあと感じています
今は ― これ
３週間くらい前なんですけれども
背丈の倍ぐらいある
笹の林を刈り倒してきました
すっごい大変だったんですけれども
まあこんな風に少しでもこんな
美味しい野菜を多くの方に
お届けできるようにするために
今は会社でも畑を作って
広げていくことを計画しています
ありがとうございました